Estoy realmente asustado, no creo que vayamos a lograrlo.
Probablemente la mayoría de ustedes habrán visto la impresionante plática de Al Gore
Poco después de verla, invitamos a algunos amigos para cenar
con la familia. La conversación se tornó hacia el calentamiento global,
y todos concordamos, que es un problema real.
Tenemos una crisis climática
Así que en torno a la mesa, discutimos sobre lo que deberiamos hacer.
La conversación llegó a mi hija de 15 años, Mary,
Ella dijo, "Estoy de acuerdo con todo lo que se ha dicho".
"Estoy asustada y molesta". Entonces volteó hacia mí y dijo:
"¡Papá, tu generación creó este problema, mejor arreglenlo!". Wow.
La platica se detuvo. Todos los ojos se dirijieron hacia mi.
(risas)
No supe que decir. La segunda ley de Kleiner es:
"Hay un momento en que el pánico es la respuesta apropiada"
(risas)
... y hemos llegado a ese momento. No podemos darnos el lujo de menospreciar
este problema. Si enfrentamos consecuencias catastróficas e irreversibles,
debemos actuar, y debemos actuar decisivamente.
Tengo que confesarles, para mí, todo cambió esa noche.
Y de esta forma, mis socios y yo, empezamos esta misión para aprender más,
para tratar de hacer mucho más. Así que nos movilizamos y subimos a los aviones.
Fuimos a Brasil. Fuimos a China y a India.
Fuimos a Bentonville, Arkansas y a Washington, D.C. y a Sacramento.
Y ahora, lo que quisiera hacer, es decirles
acerca de que aprendimos en esos viajes...
...porque al aprender más, nuestra conciencia aumentó.
Quizá sabrán, mis socios en Kleiner y yo, somos "networkers" compulsivos,
así que cuando vemos un gran problema o una gran oportunidad
como gripe aviar o medicina personalizada,
solo reunimos a la gente más inteligente que conocemos.
Para esta crisis climática, formamos una red digital, realmente
de superestrellas, desde activistas políticos hasta científicos y emprendedores
y a líderes empresariales. 50 o más de ellos.
Y entonces, quiero hablarles de lo que aprendimos haciendo eso
y las cuatro lecciones que aprendí en el último año.
La primera lección, es que las compañías son realmente poderosas,
y eso importa bastante. Esta es una historia acerca de
como Wal-Mart se volvió "verde", y qué significa eso.
Dos años atrás, el presidente ejecutivo, Lee Scott, creyó que "verde"
era el siguiente "gran asunto", así que Wal-mart hizo del "verde" una prioridad principal.
Se comprometieron a tomar todas sus tiendas existentes,
y reducir su consumo de energía un 20%,
y sus tiendas nuevas un 30%, y hacer todo esto en siete años.
Los tres grandes usos de energía en una tienda, son: calefacción y
aire acondicionado, despues iluminación, y luego refrigeración.
Entonces, miren lo que hicieron.
Pintaron los techos de blanco, de todas sus tiendas.
Pusieron tragaluces inteligentes a lo largo de sus tiendas
para poder captar la luz del día y disminuir la demanda de iluminación,
y tercero, pusieron los productos refrigerados
trás puertas cerradas con iluminación LED.
Digo, ¿Porqué tratar de refrigerar una tienda completa?
Estas son realmente simples, soluciones inteligentes basadas en tecnologí existente.
¿Porqué importa Wal-Mart? Bueno, es masivo.
Son el más grande generador de empleos en América.
Son el consumidor más grande de electricidad del sector privado.
Tienen la segunda flota vehicular más extensa en carretera.
y tienen una de las cadenas de suministro más impresionantes:
60,000 proveedores. Si Wal-Mart fuera un país,
sería el sexto socio comercial más importante junto con China.
Y quizá más importante, tienen un gran efecto en otras compañías.
Cuando Wal-Mart dice que será "verde" y lucrativo,
esto tiene un poderoso impacto en otras grandes instituciones.
Entonces, dejenme decir esto:
Cuando Wal-Mart logra 20% de reducciones de energía,
eso será un gran negocio. Pero me temo que no es suficiente.
Necesitamos que Wal-Mart y todas las otras compañias hagan lo mismo.
La segunda cosa que aprendimos es que los individuos importan,
y que importan enormemente.
Tengo otra historia de Wal-Mart para ustedes, ¿Está bién?
Wal-Mart tiene más de 125 millones de clientes en E.U.
Es un tercio de la población de E.U.
65 millones de bombillas flourescentes se vendieron el año pasado.
Y Wal-Mart se propuso vender
otros 100 millones de bombillas el proximo año. Pero no es facil.
A los consumidores no les gustan estas bombillas.
La luz es algo graciosa, iluminan muy poco,
toma un rato para que inicien.
Pero la remuneración es enorme.
100 millones de bombillas significan
que ahorraremos 600 millones de dólares en cuentas de energía,
y 20 millones de toneladas de CO2 cada año, y así año con año.
No parece ralmente dificil que los cosumidores hagan lo correcto.
Es estúpido que usemos dos toneladas de acero, vidrio y plástico
para arrastrarnos a las tiendas departamentales.
Es estúpido que pongamos agua en botellas de plastico
en Fiji y traerlas en barco aquí
(risas)
Es dificil cambiar el comportamiento del consumidor,
porque los consumidores no saben cuanto cuestan estas cosas. ¿Ustedes lo saben?
Saben cuanto CO2 han generado para manejar o volar hasta aquí?
Yo no lo sé, y debería.
Los que nos preocupamos de todo esto, actuaríamos mejor
si supieramos cuáles son los costos reales.
Pero mientras pretendamos que el CO2 es gratis,
mientras que estos usos sean casi invisibles, ¿Cómo esperamos cambiarlo?
Estoy realmente asustado, porque pienso que el tipo de cambios
que podemos esperar de los individuos,
claramente no serán suficientes.
La tercera lección que aprendimos es que la política cuenta. Realmente cuenta.
De hecho, la polítca es primordial.
Tengo una historia detrás de camaras para ustedes,
es acerca de la red de "tecnología verde" que les describí.
Al final de nuestra primera reunión, hablamos sobre
qué tipo de acciones tomaríamos, que deberíamos poner en práctica.
y Bob Epstein alzó la mano. Se puso de pie...
Saben, Bob es ese tipo de geek de Berkeley quien inició Sybase.
Bien, Bob dijo la cosa más importante que podriamos hacer ahora
es demostrar en Sacramento, California
que necesitamos un sistema basado en el mercado de acuerdos
eso limitará y reducirá los gases de efecto invernadero en California
Es necesario e, igual de importante;
es bueno para la economia de California.
Entonces, ocho de nosotros estuvimos en Sacramento en Agosto, nos reunimos
con los siete indecisos legisladores y presionamos por AB32.
¿Saben qué? Seis de esos siete votaron "sí" en favor de la enmienda,
asi que pasó, y pasó por 47 contra 32 votos.
(Aplausos)
Por favor... Gracias.
Creo que es la ley mas importante de 2006. ¿Por qué?
Porque California fué el primer estado en esta país
en establecer la reducción de 25% de gases de efecto invernadero para el 2020
Y el resultado de eso es, que vamos a generar 83,000 nuevos empleos,
4 billones de dólares al año y reducir las emisiones de CO2
por 174 millones de toneladas al año.
California emite solo el 7% de emisiones de CO2 en E.U.
Esto es solo un porcentaje y una parte de las emisiones de CO2 del país. Es un gran inicio,
pero, debo decirles -- donde inicié -- Realmente tengo miedo.
de hecho, Estoy seguro que lo de California, no es suficiente.
Aquí está una historia sobre política nacional, de la que todos podemos aprender.
Ya saben lo que dice Tom Friedman, "Si no vas, No sabes?"
Bien, fuimos a Brasil para conocer al Dr. José Goldemberg.
El es el padre de la revolución del etanol.
Nos dijo que el gobierno de Brasil establació
que cada gasolinera en el pais, contara con etanol.
y acordaron que sus nuevos vehiculos
serían "flex-fuel" compatibles, bien?
Correrian con etanol o simple gasolina.
y he aquí lo que pasó en Brasil.
ahora tienen 29,000 bombas de gasolina
esto contra 700 en E.U. y las insignificantes dos en California
y en tres años, su nueva flota de carros
se ha hecho por el 85% de flex-fuel
Comparado a E.U., 5% son flex-fuel.
¿y saben qué? La mayoría de los consumidores que los tienen, ni siquiera lo saben.
Entonces, lo que pasó en Brasil es: remplazaron
40% de la gasolina consumida por su flota de automóviles con etanol.
Esos son: 59 billones de dólares desde 1975
que no trajeron en barco desde el Medio Oriente.
Ésto ha creado un millón de empleos dentro de ese país,
y ahorrado 32 millones de toneladas de CO2. Realmente sustancial.
Es 10% de las emisiones de CO2 a lo largo de ese país.
Pero Brasil es solo 1.3% de las emisiones de CO2 en el mundo.
Así que realmente me temo que el milagro de Brasil con el etanol, no es suficiente.
De hecho, me temo que las mejores políticas que tenemos
no van a ser suficientes.
La cuarta y última lección que aprendimos
es acerca del potencial de la inovación radical.
Así que quiero hablarles sobre un problema trágico
y el gran avance tecnológico.
Cada año un millón y medio de personas muere de
una enfermedad completamente prevenible. Esta es la malaria. 6000 personas al día.
Todos por necesitar 2 dólares en costo por medicamentos
que nosotros podemos comprar en la farmacia de la esquina.
Bien, 2 dólares, 2 dólares son mucho para África.
Así que un equipo de investigadores de Berkeley, con 15 millones de dólares
de la Fundación Gates usa ingeniería para diseñar una nueva forma radical
para hacer el ingrediente clave, llamado artemisinin,
y van a hacer esa medicina 10 veces más barata.
y haciendo eso, salvarán un millón de vidas
al menos un millón de vidas al año. Un millón de vidas.
Su avance tecnológico es vida sintética.
Ésto acelera millones de años de evolución
al rediseñar bichos, para hacer productos realmente útiles.
Ahora, lo que hacen es, se meten dentro del microbio,
cambian la senda matebólica y terminan con una fábrica de vida química.
Ahora, ustedes pueden preguntar,
John, que tiene que ver con lo "verde" y la crisis de cambio climático
Bien, les diré: -- Mucho.
Hemos formado ahora una compañía llamada Amyris, y esta tecnología
que están usando puede ser usada para hacer mejores biocombustibles.
No me permitan evitar eso. Mejores biocombustibles son ralmente un gran negocio.
Eso significa que podemos precisar la ingeniería de las moléculas en la cadena de combustible
y optimizarlas con el paso del tiempo.
así, si todo va bien, van a diseñar bichos en tanques térmicos
donde van a comer y digerir azúcares para excretar mejores biocombustibles.
Supongo que es una mejor vida a través de los bichos.
Alan Kay es famoso por decir:
"La mejor manera de predecir el futuro es inventándolo"
y claro, en Kleiner, somos del tipo que se disculpa y dice:
"la segunda mejor manera es financiarlo".
Y esa es la razón por la que estamos invirtiendo 200 millones de dólares
en un amplio rango de realmente radicales nuevas tecnologias
para la inovación en tecnologias "verdes".
Y estamos animando a otros para que lo hagan también.
Estamos hablando mucho sobre esto.
En 2005, fueron 600 millones de dólares invertidos en nuevas tecnologías
del tipo que ven aquí. Ésto se duplicó en 2006 a 1.2 billones de dólares.
Pero realmente me temo que necesitamos mucho, mucho más.
Como referencia, hecho uno:
Los ingresos de Exxon en 2005 fueron de 1 billón de dólares al día.
Saben que, ellos solo invirtieron el 0.2% de ingresos en R&D(Investigación y Desarrollo)?
Segundo hecho: El nuevo presupuesto del Presidente para energía renovable
es increiblemente, un billón de dólares en total.
Menos que un día de ingresos para Exxon
Tercer hecho: Apuesto que no sabían que hay suficiente energía
en rocas calientes bajo el país, para satisfacer las necesidades de energía en América
por los siguientes 1000 años. Y el presupuesto federal
pide miserables 20 millones de dólares de R&D(Investigación y Desarrollo) en energía geotérmica.
Es casi criminal que no estemos invirtiendo más
en búsquedas de energía en este país.
Y estoy realmente preocupado porque es absolutamente insuficiente.
Así, en un año de aprendizaje, hemos encontrado un montón de sorpresas.
Quién habría pensado que un supermercado
podría hacer dinero volviendose "verde"? Quien habría pensado que
un empresario de bases de datos, podría transformar California con legislación?
quién habría pensado que el milagro del ethanol biocombustible
podría venir de un país en desarrollo en Sudamerica?
Y quién habría pensado que los científicos
al intentar curar la malaria, abririan brechas para los biocombustibles?
Y quién habría pensado que todo eso, no es suficiente?
No es suficiente para estabilizar el clima.
No es suficiente para mantener el hielo en Groenlandia lejos de derrumbes en el oceano.
Los científicos nos dijeron -- y solo están suponiendo --
que tenemos que reducir las emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero a la mitad,
y debemos hacerlo los más rápido posible.
Ahora, podríamos tener la política que hará esto en los E.U.,
pero debo decirles, solo tenemos una atmósfera,
y de alguna forma tendremos que encontrar la voluntad política
para hacerlo en todo el mundo. La carta clave en la baraja, es China.
Para dimensionar el problema, las emisiones de CO2 de China hoy, son 3.3 gigatoneladas,
las de E. U. son 5.8.De seguir así, significa
que tendremos 23 gigatoneladas de China para 2050.
Que es casi el tanto de CO2 que hay en todo el mundo.
Y si todo sigue igual, vamos a irnos a la quiebra.
Cuando estuve en Davos, El Mayor de Dalian en China fué cuestionado
acerca de su estrategía sobre el CO2, y dijo lo siguiente,
"Sabían que los americanos usan 7 veces el CO2 percapita de los Chinos"
Luego preguntó, "Por qué debería China sacrificar su crecimiento?
para que el oeste pueda ser despilfarrador y estúpido?"
Alguién tiene aquí una respuesta para él? Yo no.
Tenemos que hacer ésto económico, para que toda la gente y todas las naciones
hagan lo conveniente, lo lucrativo
y por consiguiente, el resultado esperado.
La energía es un negocio mundial de 6 trillones de dólares.
Es la madre de todos los mercados. Recuerdan al Internet???
Bien, les diré que: Tecnologías verdes --volverse verde--
es más grande que el Internet.
Ésto podría ser la oportunidad económica del siglo 21.
Más aún, si tenemos éxito, va a ser
la transformación más importante para la vida del planeta, desde que,
como dijo Bill Joy: "fuimos desde el metano al oxígeno en la atmósfera".
Ahora, aquí está la pregunta dificil, si la trayectoria de todas las compañías e individuos
del mundo, las políticas y la innovación
no va a ser suficiente... ¿Qué vamos a hacer? No lo sé.
Cada uno aquí, se preocupa por el cambiar el mundo
y ha hecho diferencia de una u otra forma.
Así que, nuestra llamada para actuar --mi llamada para ustedes--
es para hacer del "volverse verde" la siguiente "gran cosa", su gran empresa.
Que pueden hacer? Pueden volverse neutrales en Carbono
Visiten "ClimateCrisis.org" o "CarbonCalculator.com"
y compren creditos de carbon. Podrían unirse a otros líderes en el mandato,
defendiendo el tope establecido y negociar reducciones de gases de efecto invernadero en E. U.
Hay seis propuestas ahora en el Congreso, Vamos a conseguir una aprobada.
y la cosa más importante que pueden hacer, creo,
es usar su poder personal y su "Rolodex"
para guiar sus negocios e instituciones, hasta ser "verdes"
Hagan lo que Wal-Mart, consigan ser "verdes"
por sus consumidores, por sus provedores y la empresa misma.
Piensen realmente fuera de la caja.
Pueden imaginar cómo sería se Amazon o eBay o Google
o Microsoft o Apple realmente fueran "verdes"? y que ustedes lo causaron?
Esto puede ser mayor que Wal-Mart
No puedo esperar a ver que hacemos los TEDsters respecto a esta crisis.
Y realmente, realmente espero que apliquemos toda nuestra energía,
todo de nuestro talento y todo de nuestra influencia para resolver este problema.
Porque si lo hacemos, puedo esperar
a la conversacion que tendré con mi hija en 20 años.
(Aplausos).